thank you alejandro yes i'm here with uh
mvl who just finished his game against
grishok first of all welcome to
bucharest is this your first time in
romania it's my first time in romania
and i like it very much here
what are your first impressions after
going to the opening ceremony but also
the playing hall is everything uh going
okay for you i think everything's fine
the opening ceremony i thought was
brilliant
so like maybe it took a little bit too
long to my taste but
that's every chess player like uh we
want to come back to the hotel room to
to prepare for the games but otherwise i
think we had a great time
i mean it was very organized and we had
lots of good times with
the local players and uh the children
during the semester absolutely and uh
the first game was
more or less uh uneventful let's say
were you surprised by uh
alexander's strategy were you like
concerned that he might come with any
new ideas
yeah i was surprised uh and actually on
the options that
uh that he prepared something i didn't
go this
knight c5 where we have
this perpetual
and d7 so at this point you were just
worried that you might have made
some sort of no i mean i knew this is
equal but i thought maybe
maybe sasha wants bishop g5 or bishop h6
and i knew that this is also very safe
for me
but yeah i didn't expect sasha to
to make a quick draw but
you know i i take it of course i prefer
to have
fighting games and of course it's a pity
that for the first day
uh we didn't uh we already had of three
draws but
well let's hope that uh in the next days
we
will fight more and i'll definitely try
to play my part in that
and we know we're absolutely in no
condition to uh
uh question your opening choice but
you've been playing the groomfeld all
your life
uh you've played it during the
candidates as well uh what is your
thinking process
continuing to go with the grunfeld
further in your career it seems like
yeah well in general it gives good
positions and
well i mean i don't mind getting an easy
draw with black
like today of course
days where you know it's much more
difficult and also much more fighting
depends and
yeah i mean i've tried other openings as
well and
i can't say that i won't come back to
this
other openings or even completely
brand new openings at least for me but
gunfire does suited me well i know a lot
of things there so
i don't see any reason not to play it on
a regular basis
you definitely do know a lot uh you
showed us two ways in which you could
have equalized this position
uh what are your ambitions for this
tournament i want to play well
i want to come back you know into
the top 10 because i i mean for the
first time in five years i'm not in
there because of
my tournament in vacancy and um
i'm definitely hoping you know play well
with some games
and you know that's generally the
strategy you have when you want to do in
a tournament so
i can also hope for that if all goes
well
well there you have it guys a very
ambitious and
ready to fight mvl watch out back to you
guys